think this Falls in line with the idea
of anarchot tyranny that we were talking
about the my view of the modern left is
that their positions are nothing but
chaos there there's there's no logical
pathway towards preserving life uh
improving people's lives it seems to be
only it's like it's like it's like yin
yang right there's one side that's
talking about long-term planning logical
thinking and improving the world and one
side that takes the inverse position no
matter what for instance 25 people push
in front of a subway nobody bats an eye
one guy three guys try to subdue a man
and now they want prison that's like a
weird inversion of what the law is
supposed to do the law should stop the
people who are pushing people on the
trains and protect the people on the
train who are being victimized but the
left's position is the inverse of it
right
are all chaos I mean if you really
wanted to boil down what the left is
fighting for especially myself it's
expanding freedom